Learning how to identify possible data
is a fundamental skill if you're going
to work with data. You have to
see data when it isn't obvious.
Data is truly everywhere and it is almost always
more than what you initially think. Let's start
with this simple example of a chair. Think
of what data you see when you see this chair.
Did you notice that it has a color? What about
the material? And, what about it being furniture?
If we dig deeper for even more data, you will
see that the chair has dimensions like height
and weight. These things impact our shipping and
the cost of shipping. That takes us even further,
like suppliers. Where are the locations of
those suppliers? How many suppliers do we have?
And, how many chairs do they have in stock?
What about all the dates related to
the chair, like when it's ordered?
When it was shipped? When it's delivered?
Again, identifying the not-so-obvious data
can help you in a million different
ways as you start your analyst career.
Try your data lens out on the items that you
work with and see how much data you identify.
This will help you to ask better questions
in almost every data-related project.
Learning about data fields and types
It's important to understand what data looks like.
Most people will think about the values of data.
But, to an analyst, the data looks like data
types, fields and values. A data type defines what
type of data goes into a field. A date data type
will contain only dates, numbers only numbers.
It also controls what you can do with
the data values of that data type.
For example, if I need to add 30 days, then I'll
want to be sure I'm working with a date data type.
Data has so many types, and each program has
different ways to handle and format them.
Now let's get started with the basics.
Common data types are text or string, date,
date and time and number. When we first look
at data on any data set, it's typically the
field headings and the values that we see.
But as a data analyst, remember you must dig
deeper to see what types are behind that data.
Here's an example. You see both the field heading
and the value. The field name is FirstName, but
the field value is Robin. Field headings and all
the values then go on to make up records or record
sets. This probably looks familiar to you. The
spreadsheets you encounter are probably structured
with records like this already. This gives us a
lot of flexibility when working with data tools.
Depending on the data you encounter, it might
be your first step to get it into a record
set format. Data tools you will work with
will expect the data in this record format.